CBS News senior national security
analyst Fran Townsend joins us
she was homeland security advisor during
the George W Bush administration Fran
good morning it was quite an image what
does this historic moment actually mean
for nuclear negotiations you think well
it remains to be seen right the
president can make make progress I have
to say look President Trump is
unconventional in his style this is a
pretty risky both personal and political
move for him we'll think he's a genius
if he makes progress right but of course
there are concerns that this is we
front-loaded it for Kim we've given him
the benefit of the step of a sitting US
president and into North Korea we
haven't gotten much yet and so whether
should he get credit for even having
this meeting it's never happened before
even if there was a big butt with it
well yeah I do think because I I think
that it's risky right that the president
has put himself at risk showing Kim
where he's willing to reward him for
behavior that we haven't seen yet seems
to be working backwards though that's
right and and so I don't think the
president has said he will invite him to
the White House I would hope you
wouldn't see that unless there was an
agreement of some sort I don't think any
first step is going to be a total
denuclearization but it may be a
containment strategy on the way to
denuclearization and you imagine any
scenario where total denuclearization
happens not in the near term I don't I
don't think that's realistic I do think
what you what you would look for in the
first instance Tony is to stop any
additional production of fissile
material to stop ICBM testing that sort
of thing on the way to total dumi
containment right correct to what what
is the risk in effect in legitimizing a
repressive dictator in a meeting like
this you know Anthony we deal with
repressive dictators all the time look
at China as a human rights violator the
Obama administration dealing with the
Iranians who kill more of their citizens
than any regime in the world and so look
these are not people you'd want to have
at your dinner table but there are
people in the reality of geopolitics
that you need to deal with you can't
solve a problem without talking to
people should a meeting of this
significance have been so impromptu we
saw Stephanie Grisham his new White
House press secretary get jostled in the
process of this so many people seem to
been caught off guard
or if it works it doesn't matter that it
was so important to I think geld to your
point if it works well we won't care it
was impromptu I have to tell you I feel
for his staff having been on a
president's staff the notion of trying
to do this on the fly it's no easy chore
usually mapped out months in advance
very scripted yeah right Fran Townsend
thank you always good to have you here
at the table with us